you welcome everybody to episode 200
of the h3 podcast
thank you to ring and ridge the two
r's we love our sponsors there's not
many of them left folks
so we love them a lot uh today we
commemorate episode 200
with these beautiful uh shirts which
instead of it's my fupa shot but instead
of my fupa it's the earth
episode 200. it's you looking down and
reflecting
reflecting on everything we've achieved
over these past 200 episodes show the
back too
that's pretty cool the back shows our
transitions of the
at logo hopefully the improvements the
like oh is that what it is i didn't
realize
it's my favorite first version
i was like i don't know why there's
three logos but
that's amazing and the three numbers are
the three
uh color schemes that is very cool
that's the whole history of the show a
genius design
from a genius mind that belongs to ian
ian slater
you do have a genius mindy and i hope
you know that
i want to go that far but i'll take it
thank you well you don't have to go that
far
i'm saying it and frankly i'm sick of
you correcting me
uh available at h3h3shop.com
for two weeks only and the money will be
shared with our crew this is not me
hoarding gold like scrooge mcduck you
guys will get most of it all right
um you know many people would say ethan
you know over 200 episodes i'm surprised
that you're even uh still care about
this show after
um you know the show has gone downhill
everybody's uh made videos eviscerating
you on the internet
i mean how do you still care how do you
still go
on and to those people i say
i love this show i love you guys i love
the crew
and i will never quit this h3 podcast
while there's breath in my lungs
nobody will stop me and i'll tell and
i'll go one step further
we are going to be stepping it back what
is today monday
it's friday
that was so far well i knew it was the
beginning or the end
the end ela you know it is the end
for me for me it's big because when
friday hits
it means the weekend comes and that's
when we're alone with theodore there's
no help
yeah so it means i wake up at 6 a.m
so it's a bit it's something that i
cannot ignore
i'm dreading the whole wing
yes yes so it's friday big time big time
friday
okay thank you but my point of saying
that is that
this is our second episode of the week
okay
now that signifies the 200 episodes but
guess what
i'm i'm starting to think maybe it's
time for three episodes a week
cross it out baby you know what i'm
saying maybe it's time for five
episodes over here okay okay every week
dude monday through friday
who's going for that who's ready zach
zack everyone nobody wants nobody's
excited
i'm stoked i'm in thank you zach
no but we're definitely gonna be
stepping back up to two episodes a week
so we're all very happy to be here and
we thank you guys so much for sticking
with us on this
toad's wild ride through 200 episodes
also a milestone is our help campaign in
which we pledge to give
out 100 000 of our own cash which we've
done
i told elo the bleeding is finally over
because here's the thing there's a
couple of things i realized over the
course of this
help campaign um you know
look i'll admit that in the past couple
of years my perception of money has
definitely
changed when me and ela were
young bucks 500 was a godsend
you know and so when you're giving out
every day so we had another 50 000 from
brendan green he's the creator of uh
pubg he pledged he generously donated 50
000
so we gave out 150 000 total three
winners every day
500 when you're giving out 1500
every day that's a lot of money like i
don't ever spend 1500
on a single item like very rarely while
i spend that kind of money
but then you're doing it every day for a
hundred days
i mean you really get a grasp for how
much money that is you know
and and for how just how long 100 days i
mean that's over three months this is
what surprised me the most
actually how long is 100 days
so it's kind of i mean it's kind of
incredible how
you know it's both a lot of money and
not
a lot in a weird way because i it's like
when you think about it it was three
times 100
300 people doesn't seem like that many
well yeah when you see the comments it
feels like not a lot because
so many people are like i really wish it
was me but uh
nice but yeah because there was like 15
to 20 000 people entering every day and
only 300 people won over the whole
course
yeah so i don't know you know the other
thing that struck me was like
when i started when we started this i
have a bad
habit of saying i when i mean we true
right when we started this 100 days ago
i fully i was like you know 100 days i
was like that seems kind of long like
we'll probably be this will be behind us
by then
i really thought so like we had a
serious conversation and we
that was really what we thought we're
like maybe we should lower it too
yeah like 60 days like is it going to
seem irrelevant by then
i the last thing i expected was that we
would be in
in a worse position yeah a pretty much a
worse position
than we were when we started it so
and then the the other thing that struck
me was really
the amount of conspiracy that i actually
i did that not surprise you i have to
say
not only did it surprise me um
they almost convinced me that we're
doing something wrong
like it's crazy it almost feels like we
didn't just do something good
it's so weird like it's actually making
me really
reflect about how you take in things
from online and social media
how you really let it affect you because
this is something that is
undeniable to me you know there's no
like
there's no question here we're just
donating money it's a good thing out of
my bank account that should hurt that's
a lot of money it's a good thing
period and then the fact that people
actually manage
to make you feel bad about it or i don't
know
it's weird but that but it did get to me
so there was immediately conspiracy
where every winner would be like there
was a
problem i mean in the scope of the
amount of people entering a
very small amount of people but
dedicated where they would
comb through the history of every winner
trying to prove that they were either
bots or a fake account
the two the conspiracy was that it
wasn't a real giveaway and that we had
we had made tons of fake accounts to
fake giving away the money
which seems like a lot of work why yeah
what do you stand to gain from it so
you just like free retweets do you think
you just want those no i want the
i want the good will that i gave away a
hundred thousand dollars but this way i
don't have to give away anything
but you know that's like fraud i feel
like that would be a really stupid thing
but look there's no logic but like the
people the actual winners
uh many of them had to turn their
accounts private
because they were getting harassed yeah
by these [ __ ] weirdos who are
convinced that it was all
a weird conspiracy so either people were
accusing the winners of just have
being bots and like scamming or they
were accusing us of faking the giveaway
i'm sure it was a small amount of people
but it was surprising
and it just is really representative of
the amount of conspiracy and just
how the negativity rises you know how
well there's people conspiratorial about
everything these days
and it's interesting because
it doesn't come from you know there's
definitely some foundation to it there
have been people that have
done fraudulent gofundme pages and
fraudulent you know donation things and
they actually just stole the money so
it's fine to be critical of things but
i don't know i found it interesting too
that uh
the the origin of a lot of these
conspiracy theories was that
the service that we were using to do the
drawing
um you know uh it automates all of it so
people would enter and then
um i was the one that was doing the
drawing so you know i'd run the draw
and it would pick three people and then
i would go through and manually
inspect their accounts just to double
check that basically to address
what those people were concerned about
make sure that it's a real person
and that it's not a bot or something and
if it did seem like it was a bot
i would redraw manually and then give it
to somebody else instead
and then because i was doing that people
thought
you know we weren't on the up and up and
were accusing us of giving it to bots
when really
it was the exact opposite of that like
we were
our action of trying to make sure that
real people were getting the money is
what
fueled the conspiracy theory so it just
well because in the beginning people
were saying oh you're not vetting these
people you're giving all the money away
to bots so we said okay
we're going to vet we're like that's
fair i'm sure there are people who
are just botting it trying to win and
right so i said okay
let's vet the winners just look at them
over and make sure that they're real
people as best as you you know as
reasonably as you can
and so a few times dan would as he said
acts one and then they go
oh these are the three winners you
originally picked so something's
you know yeah anyway
you know i wish we could help more
people i mean but i'm happy we're able
to help in some small way
and um it was a it was a it was a
interesting ex uh you know experiment i
i want to keep finding ways to help
because i feel like yeah i mean it's a
drop in the bucket 300 people and now
here we are it's like 20 unemployment
and god knows man i don't even know i
really wonder now what's gonna start
happening because evictions are starting
to
happen right and i haven't heard
but i know there was like a a freeze on
evictions
and there was basically people who are
unemployed are getting an extra 600
on top and that's helping a lot of
people and i know that was slated to end
at the end of this month
so i don't know what's gonna happen i
know i don't have enough money to give
all those people 500
i'll be on unemployment myself um
anyway the good news is that
through helping people and caring about
coronavirus i have made it
to a trump supporter
stock liberal meme
i don't know i made it to this so you
know how on twitter people go these are
the people in the replies and they post
like um
you know i think it started with people
goofing on trump supporters because it
just shows a bunch of dudes
with huge glasses sitting in a truck
yeah like the sunglasses
they're all like q and on and whatever
so here is that
the version of that for libtards and i
don't know why i made it
what did i do why did i go lip tight
dude that's why
damn i i don't know why i'm being
classified as a libtard
i accept the title though i guess that's
pretty funny
i mean i don't really fit the bill
because all these people are kind of
candid photos and here i am
that's like a from a video you know
so how do you feel being married to a
lib tart dealer i have no problem with
that
oh thanks for saying that i don't like
it
like why what what is it do you like it
or do you not like it
were any of the other people
recognizable no
no well actually one oh yeah they're
steven universe
rebecca sugar the creator of steven
universe wanted the greatest show
of all time okay that's her but like
you're in good company whatever yeah i
think it's a compliment
i don't i just why did i get this title
why am i being derided as a libtard you
just
uh look great in that photo with a
beanie i gotta start wearing glasses and
just drive a pickup truck i'm over as
[ __ ]
nobody can nobody can stereotype me well
let's
wait for my cyber truck to all right
that is a libtar card i'm sad to say
okay also exciting news
belle delfin a friend of the show is
back can i is there any personal info in
this picture
i'm it's all pretty fuzzy you can cut
you can blur it if you know i looked at
it though and it's
totally so belle you know friend of the
show um
she just out of the blue we've been
working on this for like a month she's
like hey
i'm coming back to the internet i want
to send you
a package to celebrate for you to open
on the show
this was like a month ago and then last
week she's like
i was like man i i wonder if she forgot
about us because i hadn't heard from her
in a while
then a couple days ago she's like all
right here they are
i want you to open them in this order
one two three these are like
big ass packages one of them is here
it's like
basically as tall as i am but the third
one is so
this one is caught in customs and i
really pray that it's
not something so weird that they just
like send or trash it
so we cannot open them because there's
an order
yeah she says don't open them if customs
open it make sure your guys
like keep it a secret you have to order
it in this specific
you have to open it in this specific
order we have two of them i i mean what
could it be these are huge packages
and by the way she must have cost her a
fortune to see yeah
i mean the red one is like as tall as a
person yes
it's a solid five feet tall for sure
i love her and she she shipped them like
two day or something from the uk to los
angeles
it's got to be stupid someone someone
guessed maybe she's in the box
yeah no way i said zach would love that
talk to me baby vin diesel would love
that if that was in the box
van diesel would totally creep on bell
why why did i end up in beautiful world
so i really have no guess honestly
this one's a painting i predict this one
is like she was selling paintings where
she put like
paint on her vag and [ __ ] and sat
so i'm thinking that's what this is but
i could that's what it is
how are we gonna ever explain that to
theodore when he's i'll say
theodore there's a girl named belle who
put paint on her vag and sat on a canvas
and sent it to you your dad
is so good this one i have no idea
yeah uh is maybe it's like a full-size
cutout of her
the tall one yeah maybe do you think
she's that short she could be
yeah yeah it's like five feet tall i
mean i think
ian uh ran into her at the pornhub
awards she was really short right
i'm not like super short okay yeah you
know not
normal girls yeah normally no it's like
five feet i think that's reasonable
i'm saying it's a real doll it's too
thin how could it be a real doll
a real doll can press maybe you have to
inflate it's very light it's too light
to be real though
ela if bell sent us a real doll would
you allow me to [ __ ] it
absolutely not no okay just curious
is that cheating
it's not but i just disapprove not that
i would want to i'm just
well it sounds like you want i know like
it's a good question here we go
i think it's a good question okay well
the answer is no
okay good to know i won't do it i
wouldn't do it anyway
zach's like so you you throw it out
right
who gets it
what time does your garbage collect so
do we keep it in the prop room
would you be offended if zack had sex
with the real doll
no and then but but then she's like well
it's yours you've got to keep it so zach
[ __ ] it but then we have to keep it at
our house
i mean she's sending it for the show
right it's not to you personally it
should be on set
not in zach's closet you're saying it's
a communal
real doll
[ __ ] it i don't want to handle it
i don't know we bought for one of my
friends in college
uh his girlfriend was like lived in
france or whatever so we thought it'd be
funny to buy him
a fleshlight for his birthday and um
wait for it this gets good and um
this was like when flashlights were new
and it was like the weirdest thing right
so we went to a six store together and
we
we each chipped in we bought him at we
thought it'd be specifically funny to
buy him an
[ __ ] flesh because you got like the
mouth
the veg and the [ __ ] okay i think the
mouth might be the funnier one
debatably because you're just like
pounding a mouth
like a disembodied mouth regardless of
which one's
on there we decided on the [ __ ] so we
brought it home we wrapped it up for him
we gave him the gift he thought it was
funny
yada yada flash forward a month later
we're all drunk drinking
so it was three of us that pitched in
for the flash the fleshlight
one of my friends admitted while he was
drunk
that he [ __ ] the fleshlight before
giving it to him
what i swear to god he test drove the
fleshlight
before giving it to him how the
how about that [ __ ] and he like washed
it out put it back in the package
crazy i can't do that i know but it
happened
the eskimo brother that's nasty
i've i have kind of a similar story to
that um my buddy bought one
and he used it a couple times and he
thought he could sell it he did
some kid at our high school bought it a
used [ __ ] fleshlight
bro this isn't a car or a bike you can't
sell a used flashlight
did he clean it at least he just put it
under water
he just put it underwater
i mean can you even watch this stuff
properly like i
better than with water yeah you'll get
in there with some soap and a brush like
you clean up a baby bottle
yeah just like it well this was not that
thorough i'll tell you that did he
sell it marked down or was it like like
how was the deal for him do you remember
he sold it for half price
half price wow that's disgusting
did the guy know it was used yeah he did
and he didn't give a [ __ ]
okay so at least he knew what he was
getting
damn kids are so horny they'll do that's
disgusting
they are they really are you have any
other i
i i i remember a story it's not really
sexual but
it's disgusting when i was in middle
school
uh two of my f i won't say friends but
acquaintances
were beefing they didn't like each other
so he get
one the one friend has a half drinking
bottle of coke and he decides to go in
the bathroom and piss in it
why and then he gives that bottle to the
other guy he's beefing with
oh and you know what's funny about kids
he goes hey you want this coke bottle
and the other kid's like yeah sure
thanks
like just out of nowhere for no reason
hey you want this coke bottle
yeah he's like yeah of course i want
coke and then he
he drinks it gross and he spits it out
he says it tastes like piss
go to the hospital or the hospital go to
the principal
the police get involved and it was this
whole crazy thing where the police were
interrogating us
and uh it was this whole crazy thing to
be honest with you
but the moral the story really is that
um you had some bad influence around you
this is like this wasn't a daily
occurrence these are the story that pops
out
but the the moral of the story really is
that um
kids are [ __ ] stupid and disgusting
yeah right you don't have any stories
like that
girls putting used tampons and stuff oh
that sounds like guys stories i don't
know
yeah no me girl [ __ ]
no honestly i have like almost zero
memories
from anything i feel like i have real
memories
i feel like it's all been blocked yeah
it could be the medicine i slip in uh
i give you i give you amnesia medicine
so you don't leave me
it could be that that might explain a
couple of things
um so i'm a stock liberal we got belt
you know i just
watched watchmen you finished oh right
yeah
and i love it and you just reminded me
that i wish that i could take those
memory appeals
maybe you forget for a reason yeah
probably
i don't want to relive those horrible
i'm so glad i'm not in high school
yeah i'm glad i'm not like in puberty
and all that i mean that sucks
i hated all that so probably
probably chose not to remember well they
they say the brain has perfect memory
but that
forgetting things is a survival tactic
so that you can you know move past
trauma and
mature and grow and um
and that that it's that it's a critical
for for our well-being to forget things
so maybe you're just more evolved highly
doubt it
you know what i've been trying to do
recently is i've been trying to get lots
of sleep
recently as in the past two days but i
feel like i just i walk around and i
feel so bad all the time i don't
understand why
and you know i feel like i'm super sleep
deprived
and so why are you shaking your head and
so what i've been trying to do is go to
bed earlier
and make sure i'm getting eight hours of
sleep every night and i woke up this
morning feeling good
now ela go ahead and tell me why you're
disappointed in me
because i don't know you wake up at like
11 to 1
sometimes yeah i agree but not lately so
just hearing that you think that you're
sleep deprived
it's just a little bit of it well
because i'm up to like five
so just start there don't be up till
five
that's what i'm that's what i'm saying
why are you trying to
that's what i'm saying
geez let me have a w for once
yeah i went to bed last night at like
12.
really i mean the same time as you was
in bed same time as you
okay yeah cool cool because you slept
until 11 00. yeah i'm catching up
okay okay but do you get sleepy also
are you talking to yourself zack that's
a strange sound bite to have
it was strangely appropriate though it
was
anthony can i bring something up yes
i can't just not talk about the fact
that you have a mustache all of a sudden
oh yeah we can i mean that'd be weird to
just
not address it right well i've had this
we had an episode with idubbbz
yeah complimented his mustache and then
we come back two days later and you have
a mustache
well it wasn't i i don't think it was
directly related although the timing is
suspicious so who knows
but i have had i have had this
this look before yeah and i saw pictures
of myself
back then and i thought it looked pretty
good my beard was getting long so i was
shaving last night before the show
and i just decided to leave this part
and i thought hey you know what
let's leave the mustache but it's
different i feel like then
if you shave all this and just leave the
mustache i don't think i could pull that
off
i think you need all this to kind of
blur
what's going on here and it kind of
works as a full picture
and does it work though because it feels
almost like
undecisive uh yes
it does work okay thank you for asking
no i like it i think it's cool because
it's like i like that it's undecisive
okay i like it and i got the uh escobar
kind of like yeah
like like like craig escobar craig
oh who is craig the brother is that the
only one on the phone
his uncle or something but his name is
actually craig no i'm just saying
that's the vibe i'm just making yeah you
guys are dumping on me i get it
so what's the process how did you trim
it did you just use like a
bigger guard sides and
i have a beard trimmer and then
basically i just
i cut everything but i do like a five
here i do like a four down here
i bring the guard on the neckline and
then here
i just cleaned up i just cleaned it up a
little bit i didn't really cut it at all
you know i think it looks dope i think
you see zach
you know i should be married to zach
we might have to throw up a twitter poll
this weekend
mustache ethan oh you could throw it up
i'm not saying that i don't like it
so i'm not like to quote you directly
you said
does it work though
i'm just wondering if it's a look like
can this be a look the mustache i think
it is a lot and
beard like halfway because it almost
feels like
make up your mind cool right yeah i
think it's cool
i'm not saying that i don't like it i
think it is a look
and if it's not one it will be one i
like it
what do you think ian uh i'm pro
i'm pro mustache bro mustache yeah but
what about like the
the stubble stash
think that's yeah you got to do this
double stash because i don't want
a bare face i mean that's a nightmare
yeah i kind of agree with you
i preferred this over
the traditional yeah yeah
ela's disgusted by me when i shave not
by you i don't like in general i shave
those he goes really i walk out with a
clean [ __ ] and face she goes
do you really expect me to look at you
like that not true
disgusted by me um
you know what i found out an open book
maybe it's too open sometimes
uh you know what we were looking
i don't know what was the genesis for
this but
what was the genesis for this we have
everybody's high school yearbook photo
the whole gangs i don't know where it
came from
oh i think it was just i we started with
i showed dan my yearbook photo
i forgot about it and somebody from the
subreddit went to my high school
and i guess they have like an archive of
everyone that went there
and they posted a photo this is my high
school graduation
senior picture pokemon pokemon shirt
because everyone else was in a suit you
know
and they not have a like requirement no
they don't know
it's just i guess you know everyone
wants to look nice because it's their
senior picture
but i i they look so lame because you're
like in puberty
your body's weird you don't fill in a
suit nicely
and these are not like tailored suits
these are like
rented suits that don't even fit you
well i think this was a really
smart choice and ahead of its time
thank you thank you very much for saying
that iconic
yeah i did i knew i didn't want to wear
a suit because it's just you look like
such a
phony lame-o it's like dude you know i'm
gonna you know come on
stop fronting did your parents give you
[ __ ] for not wearing the suit
um actually not they don't care
i don't think they even my parents were
so uninvolved in my life i don't even
think they knew that it was taking place
because
i had to go somewhere specifically it
wasn't on campus to get the photo
so i was just like hey we're doing
photos you know i need to check whatever
they didn't even know that that's this
was
what it was so i think my mom just saw
the yearbook it was like oh ethan
something like that and that was it
my parents were very uninvolved in my uh
my mom
jokingly calls me a feral child i'm like
funny to you i was the loveless child
that nobody cared about
she goes my sister goes oh they were so
hands off with you they allowed you to
do anything i was like yeah they didn't
[ __ ] care about me they didn't do
[ __ ]
maybe it's for the best yeah it is for
the best
anyway here's ela who looks exactly the
same
um was this uh this was your senior year
i guess so high school i guess so you
pretty much
no idea but i think that is it i asked
my mom
it almost became a fight just trying to
get her to get a picture
she's the first picture she said was all
blurred or it was super far away she
took a picture of the whole page i was
like can you
could she not get a closer photo and
it's like moms do this thing where they
just talk and you keep asking and they
just ignore and they just keep talking
right and i kept asking like did you tap
to get it to focus on
right i had to ask it like five times in
a row it's really exhausting
yeah mom's mom brain um but she got it
so i
look fuller in the face but um
i don't know what happened you look hot
dude
you look [ __ ] good as [ __ ] my hair is
the same
i mean you look no no yeah you look very
similar
that's kind of how i remember you back
when i first met you because when i
first met you you were 19.
yeah we were young kids when we first
met but you didn't
look like your yearbook picture so oh i
guess because you were older
right well that you were like photo of
my name i was 18.
yeah you were 21. and when i met you i
must have been
yeah 21 exactly
so three years difference
college you've been yeah i went through
i was through dan
did you look like straight out of uh
freaking cakes bro
totally you know what i mean
totally such a sweet kid the outfit is
pretty crazy
yeah i think i picked all that up at a
at a thrift shop
like a couple days before the shoot
because is this corduroy
yeah it was quarter wow yeah epic
that's actually i kept that i kept that
jacket for a while because i thought it
was pretty cool
do you fit into it still no i doubt it
yeah no way actually
you look nice you look sweet yeah you
look like a sweet kid
stylish
young zach looks exactly literally the
same this was not like a month ago
yesterday yeah
no but seriously how long ago was this
photo zach i've been out of high school
four years
oh it's four years old yeah i guess
you've aged gracefully
well thank you
ian's is my favorite here we go bring on
the jokes
here we go this is the [ __ ] best i
don't want to say anything but
god damn so ian how long ago was this
photo
uh that was eight years ago oh
the hair is very smosh yeah
it's very uh i picked up a skunk
roadkill and duct taped it to my
forehead
as your hair dyed you dyed your hair
black right
uh yeah there was a phase that's awesome
but you look so sweet and nice were you
emo
at this period is this an emo phase
it was kind of like a rebrand because i
i just
i just got my braces off and i ordered
some contacts
and then i was like mom we're dying the
hair today
this is a new ian that's crazy i was
never
really my parents actually never let me
do anything like
if i wanted to color my hair or do
anything they didn't allow me to
lie insane did they think because
they're provocative or something
i don't even know yeah probably i don't
know because you're psychological your
dad was like a
tyrant also very conservative so it's
almost like
so this is just making me think like i
wonder what i would have done
with my hair but um i wasn't allowed to
you want to do something with your hair
now
you're ceo now you do whatever you want
purple
i don't like purple hair green i don't
like
no red i only like gray gray
dye your hair white that'd be so weird
don't do that
don't worry you got plenty of time you
want to try the the swoopy bowl cut
i don't know how you would even achieve
that yeah
how did you get a fishbowl hair or
helmet hair
ah that'd be a question for my mom oh
your mom's
not a hairdryer so she would do it yeah
you got the biebs look going on dude
right it's the biebs look that's what it
is yeah that was very in at the time
that's everyone
it was did you get chicks back then with
this look
dude in high school you clean up move on
clap those cheeks just like jimmy lee
huh
oh that was a sound bite see i'm getting
messed with
wait were you saying move on or they
used to clean up
high school i wasn't that successful no
you were
i didn't well to be uh to i mean
i didn't lose my virginity until i was
in college
so until i was 19. not to heal
that was yeah we didn't have sex for a
while until actually
when we met so like
blew your mind
actually we met when we were 21 i don't
think
we had sex until like many years later
when you came
to stay with me during that summer um
it's not many years several years
right i think it's one
oh really because it felt like a longer
many years this is awesome though
elo my folks were the same way i
couldn't do like i had to be
yeah yeah like i didn't grow my hair
graduated high school that's why i look
the same
so boring i love this stuff i love these
pictures man
anyway let's move on everybody looks
beautiful everyone's beautiful
we should uh do our break we're over
okay let's do a uh ad break guys we'll
be right back when we come back
jake paul you know that's the mayor of
l.a
uh chastised jake paul he moved to
calabasas in
shame now the mayor of calabasas is
shaming jake paul
for throwing parties during covid with
no social distancing or masks
find out all about it when we come back
from this
commercial break
ring is a product that i recommend
without reservation
to anybody on this planet you know this
time of year we're coming up on the
holidays
kind of but we're all at home we're
ordering lots of stuff
people are stealing packages right off
the porch ring
lets you see what actually happened
that's just one reason of a billion i'm
talking about home security
i'm talking about a two-way camera that
tells you when there's motion
on your phone anywhere in the world i'm
talking about the technology to
talk to them and say hey dude get off my
porch
that video gets recorded and beamed up
to the cloud so even if some slick
wet bandits that's a home alone thing
right the wet bandits
i don't know yeah that was what they
called themselves because they flood i
don't know they flooded the house anyway
if some slick
wet bandits come and try to clip your
power
guess what the video is already beamed
up to the cloud
where our consciousness will soon follow
uh
i recommend ring i mean it's it's the
best product in the market for home
security
at our house we had like six of them
it's literally a ring of security and i
slept so peacefully knowing that
nobody could creep up to our house and
if anything did happen i would have a
recording
on of it in the morning on the internet
like seriously it's just i can't
recommend it enough
they've got the video doorbell that lets
you answer the door and check in on your
home at any time
keep an eye on your doorstep or speak to
delivery people when you can't come to
the door
they've got outdoor security cameras so
you can check in on every part of your
house and never miss a moment
smart lighting brightens up blind spots
to make sure you always come home to a
brightly lit house
full home security systems give you
everything you need to protect your
family
your pets your property and they also
have a community the ring community
on the app it's got everybody in your
neighborhood who has it which is a lot
sharing notes talking about things that
happen i found it to be really
actually really interesting and useful i
spent a lot of time browsing that
we have a special offer for our audience
get a special
uh ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com
h3 the welcome kit includes the ring
video doorbell 3 and chime pro
it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today so
just go to ring.com h3 that's ring.com
slash h3
oh
2001 space odyssey technology we as
human beings have advanced
and advanced times the day of coin
purses
so why is it we're still walking around
with wallets from the 1920s when the
future is here and we need to be using
ridge wallet ridge wallet is the only
wallet you will need to buy for the rest
of your life
it's powerful it's structural it will
never be
damaged and it's so slick it's so modern
that it's just perfectly designed to fit
in your put for
in your front pocket without causing any
harm first of all
coins we don't need coins let's face it
a quarter what really is a quarter worth
this day and age coins
are out all you need is a slot for the
bills right here
and a slot for credit cards that slide
right in here easily
now i use a ridge myself but ela doesn't
allow me to bring it to show you guys
because i always bring it out and show
my credit card numbers
on accident i can't be helped so i'm not
showing you the one that i use
because either forbids it but you can
show how the card would go in
i guess yeah the card would just they
just pop in they pop out you could
you could fit a bunch of cars in here
and it's just so seamless it's beautiful
um the ridge wallet it holds up to 12
cards
plus room for cash there's over 30
colors
and styles including carbon fiber and
bur
titanium look at these beautiful walls
pretty slick pretty beautiful i really
like the uh the burnt titanium actually
each wallet is made with rfid blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pit puckers oh that's so
cool another reason why it's so hardcore
you know what they do they like people
have like scanners in their pockets and
they can
stand next to you and scan your card i
don't know because a lot of people have
like that chip that sends like a little
wi-fi that you slide
and so this actually protects against
digital pip pockets
um if it wasn't enough to win you over
yet check out their 30
000 5 star reviews boom everybody loves
the ridge wallet
the durable material means each wallet
comes with a lifetime warranty
you could buy this one wallet and carry
it for life the ridge team is so
confident that you'll like it
they'll let you try it for 45 days you
can send it back for a full refund if
you don't
love it wow that's pretty incredible
and today get 10 off
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to
ridge.com h3 and use code
h3 when you check out the ridge wallet
give it a shot i mean you got 45 days to
try it and see if you like it
give a kiss we love you ridge
welcome back as promised now we will
discuss
jake paul are you ready ela so ready
so it where where logan paul i have to
say
seems to have matured a bit since
filming a corpse in the forest
uh jake paul has has
only receded almost yeah they're almost
like going in the opposite directions
now completely
i mean this should this story is really
something jake paul
moved to calabasas he's got this big
house there
and well here's the clip they got the
mayor and the city
super upset this just happened oh is
this going to get us planned
shows a scene that will have local
health officials pounding their heads
against the wall
look at this show young people crowded
together at youtube personality jake
paul's calabasas mansion on saturday
partying away in the middle of a panda
this is
awful as our neighbor
hanging out no math no no all the
neighbors are like wow outside and
outside day and night and two days after
this
we went right back into stricter
lockdowns yet again
as gatherings like this spread of the
virus according to officials
you think whoever's operating that crane
is has a proper license
calabasas mayor alicia says she got a
barrage of phone calls from angry
residents
and she shares in their frustration
they're having this large party but
to show it with no social distancing no
mask it's just a big
huge disregard for everything that
everybody's trying to do
to get things back to functioning
it's really just a part is being the
mayor of calabasas like just being the
hoa president
it's like just such a small little town
outside l.a
acting like covid does not exist it's
acting that
businesses aren't closed not far from
the mansion this row of calabasas small
businesses are now shut
down again that includes a hair salon a
nail salon
and several others the mayor says they
pay the price
for behavior like this our businesses
are not going to be able to reopen our
children are not going to be able to go
back to school
and we all have to do our part as a
result of this party mayor weintraub
says she got [ __ ] up
she saw that there will now go back
upstairs
not going to be able to go back to
school and they have literal helicopters
peeping on his house
there's a giant panda on his roof
jesus dude how immature can this guy be
i'm just thinking mayor weintraub says
she got into like the only person
um i can think of that would think this
is cool is theodore
theodore loves tractors that's like his
dream i was like why are you
why are you insulting our poor son he's
one year older
he would love this party yeah he loves
tractors
we should get a tractor at his next
birthday party
um
sheriff's station and there will now be
a zero tolerance policy
on house parties no more warnings
straight enforcement
no gatherings will be tolerated like
this something like this will not happen
again
your message to jake paul jake paul has
actually done a lot of really good
things in our community before
with the youth and i just hope that he
can continue
to have different actions and
show that everyone should be wearing a
mask and social distancing and not
throwing parties
jesus gonna kill someone with that crane
bro so
jake paul single-handedly changed the
policy
straight enforcement brah but it gets
better
um let's see
here is a bunch of videos let's let's
show
some perspective from the neighbors oh
this is in the party
so my favorite part about this is
there's another youtuber tanner fox
okay tanner fox was at that party
and he was filming videos with all of
jake and his crew
without masks without social distancing
now a few days after that party
tanner fox calls jake paul
to tell him he has kovid
and he films him candidly which is
pretty epic
i don't know why he did it like this but
i enjoyed it
you know these guys are they're like hey
content first bro
i mean this is amazing and jake doesn't
give a [ __ ]
i love how this guy turns in him having
coveted into content
he's just calling everybody and
recording their reaction like bro mm-hmm
like just what the [ __ ]
hello hello yo nice to
meet you where is this yo man hey jake
hello hey bro um so
i have some i have some bad news
oh man so
we filmed a video about two days ago and
this morning
i woke up and i felt a little bit off so
i went and got
a kobe 19 test and it actually came back
positive
you're tripping i'm really not lying
demon
nah you're tripping that couldn't be it
couldn't be possible that any of us have
covered
we've been totally safe i'm being honest
bro so i know i was around you and your
in your team
and again i i just started showing very
small symptoms of it today
but i wanted to call you and i had to
let you know i really just
got tested for it you just got tested
did you get your results back
no so just to tell you guys if he got
so if you're around someone who's
positive you're supposed to quarantine
for two weeks
because if you get tested right
afterwards it may not show you because
if let's say that tanf box infected jake
paul and he got tested
the same day or the next day it's
useless uh
yeah i i don't know what to tell you i'm
joking i'm really not joking right now
man i swear
i swear to god i am however filming this
without telling you
are you are you worried about it
not really
okay well that's good but i had to call
you and just let you know
um i just started showing symptoms of it
today so i don't know how
how long it's been contagious but
um i i just i'm glad you guys all got
tested then already
it's crazy how like you literally called
as i closed the door on the doctor too
you literally just took a test yeah like
five minutes ago
oh my god okay well when you guys get
your test results back let me know
all right so jake paul goes not really i
don't care
and then you know what's interesting so
so this guy was like hey i'm positive i
was at your party i've been with you
and then jake paul if you go to his
channel he's still living his life like
like he's still out and about
um which is obviously concerning i mean
that party could potentially spread it
to so many
super spreading event they call it yeah
um he posted a video one day ago
he's like yo he's like hey bro i have
covid they're like all right cool well
we're gonna head down to the beach and
interview people
hey can you put down your mask for this
by the way that's cool i can breathe
crazy right now that he knows he was in
contact with someone who's positive he's
supposed to quarantine for two weeks
this is work this is so much worse than
filming a dead body this is maybe the
worst thing he's done because
his actions could actually kill yeah
yeah
it's awesome how much of a [ __ ] he is
like i mean this is crazy look what is
so hard for people to understand that
it's not yeah he's like hey lady he's
like
hey breathing in their face heavy like
if you're not being safe
it doesn't show that you're more manly
or anything like that or more courageous
or i don't know what
it just shows that you don't care for
other people and potentially
i mean your actions could end up with
someone dying
of course not direct that's the thing to
understand it's like no you're
you're not gonna like you're gonna get
all your friends sick and then one of
their grandmas is gonna get sick or
their parents are gonna you can get it
and have no symptoms
but that's fine but while you do that
you're gonna give it to 20 other people
he's going to kill this porn starbuilder
by the way so he's hanging out with a
porn star and they obviously have sex
for a living so
that's not going to be good for her
career i think
unless they put not good for anything
unless they [ __ ] through a hole in the
wall
like the government suggested ethan stop
stop touching your micron
people doing wholesome things by the way
the new thing on youtube is just get a
porn star in your video
uh that's something the paul brothers
are both doing
uh logan got um what's the name of that
girl
very famous porn star what's her name
lana rhodes what's her name
lana rhodes yeah and then he got you got
this girl what's her name emily willis
so there you go and of course tana
sex tape jake is pretty much just
producing soft core pornography at this
point
so there you have it that that to me is
probably the worst thing he's ever done
mm-hmm i mean this is so [ __ ] up
but the the cream on top is the guy
calling him and saying i'm covered
positive and he's like it's chill
i don't care we don't care
his friend screams love it what is that
mentality yeah it's pretty wild
oh there's another youtuber called
pretty boy fredo i don't know who this
guy is but
he had a fan meet up in new york city
during covid this was just recently when
was this posted let's see
this was from july 19th so only a few
days ago
what are they doing why do you have to
do this now in new york
i'm surprised the mayor of a lot of this
isn't even allowed
so here's here's pretty boy fredo
in new york city july 19th
is this not illegal and they're all
screaming and jumping
damn people are hyped about pretty boy
fredo though
do any of you guys know anything about
this guy
[ __ ] told me whoa all right
pause it if you want to hear what they
say i don't i mean he's just screaming
no the guys yeah does anyone know
anything about pretty boy fredo nothing
nada it says it's a oh no dude he's
doing a coven 19
this is dude
he's doing a he's doing a fundraiser for
coven19 on this video
we turned off comments too i noticed bro
you know how you can help
not do this video wait is twitter
private too because i think he got a lot
of heat so he probably turned this
on only after you got a lot of [ __ ]
wonderful
someone else's uh doesn't have many
dislikes though
yeah the did the like ratio is really
good
interesting i bet you this is someone
else's campaign
well yeah probably
what a good guy doing uh what a good guy
he's doing a charity for covid19
well even the video it does say ssh
charity basketball event
or something bro what the [ __ ] couldn't
you figure out a way to raise money for
kova that doesn't include
whatever this is oh
we got music here's a video from
from the outside let's see what this is
oh my god look at these people so many
people
like statistically speaking
i would assume that at least a couple of
people will die as a result of this i
mean that's crazy
you know what i mean right same with
jake's party like st just
just from probability i think
they indirectly are killing people
it's so wild
damn so wild i just i really don't
understand what's so hard
to understand you're not just showing
that you're
a macho by not caring and
oh i don't care if i get sick i can't
handle it it's not about that
yeah i mean we understand but they don't
but what's so hard to understand
that's what i that's what drives me
crazy it's so simple
i think for young people like that it's
cool to not care about anything
apathy is like taken over
apathy is the like caring about stuff is
uncool anything
that's kind of like the counterculture
with with
people his age i find that on youtube
too like
if you care about anything uh you're
sticking your neck out apathy is the
only cool way to go through the world
um
crazy huh i don't know why he's not
getting more [ __ ] for this because this
is actually the worst thing he's ever
done in his career
in my opinion
i mean logan paul could film a dozen
dead bodies and it wouldn't be as bad as
this
he could go dig up corpses out of the
grave and film it and it wouldn't be as
bad as this
you want to see something weird i've
been noticing on instagram this is
phenomenon
where you cut they cut the woman's hair
with a butcher knife on a cutting board
they just go medieval on her hair and at
first you're like
this looks really interesting um because
i think we've all wondered hey what's
the deal with all the cutting and
[ __ ] just do a straight cut and be
done with it
but what's funny is when they stand up
it always looks like
really like dog [ __ ] like here
we got music that already doesn't look
perfect but so then they
somehow they think that
whatever that is they're doing yeah he's
mincing
he's like a chef he's like i'm not a
barber look at this it looks
[ __ ] good it looks crazy yeah
is that supposed to be it or does it
then go no
that's it that's it
so i have a bunch of these but her hair
looks dog [ __ ] yeah
so here let's there's a bunch of them
this one's got music too dan warning
yeah so here we go you're done this is i
love that that
makes it all better just chopping the
end up
it's not straight at all no it looks
horrible
i mean i don't get it it's super uneven
yeah maybe it's a meme i mean it seems
like
serious people are doing it and getting
it done they all look like the
it's somewhere in asia right oh what is
this
what in god's name am i watching is that
a joke about it
what an axe it's so close to her head
and there's wood flying everywhere this
looks like a murderer
russian stylist this is real look how
scared she is
whoa this is for real just use scissors
at this point
yo this is like caveman [ __ ] oh he's in
a parlor look
is this not a parody no they're in a
they're in a salon who found this one
bro you're cutting her bangs with that
axe
that looks like a parody dude get that
axe away from my head
they call this through the siberian
sweeney todd
well to be more spray
her hair looks better than the other
people's
but i'm he did put a little bit more
effort into that i find this terrifying
like there's wood flying everywhere like
bro look
it looks like he's killing her there's
wood that is way too close to her head
no
she's so aggressive about it why does he
lift it so much oh she looks scared this
is not right
this is so dumb you could definitely use
a scissor in that case
that looks painful wow that
i didn't expect at all
i don't like crap i don't like it i
don't like it
i don't i do i do not like that for sure
oh is this a different guy there's
another dude with the axe
and hammer this is cutting hair with an
ax and a hammer
wait what he's what
oh [ __ ] he's like going down to the
scalp with an ax and a hammer
this guy is way too calm for this that
is crazy
see in this case i feel like the tools
that we have are sufficient
the advancements we've made in hair
cutting technology is sufficient
that's a nice spray though i haven't
seen the green look decent
that was a really good looking fade
wow that is shocking
i didn't know you could cut hair with an
acid really sharp
that's a really good looking fade i have
to agree
careful not to cut off the ear i know
whoops
and i oop what was that from
and i oop oh dr phil dr phil
oh no and i oop
i i do like it i do like the fame
i like it is it worth losing an ear for
it was a nice fade not gonna lie
so with covet 19 sports are coming back
people are trying to figure out how to
do this and there's a lot of excitement
baseball for example mlb they have
replaced the crowd
with cardboard cutouts
and they have fans booing and cheering
to influence
the stadium look at these cardboard
cutouts
dantila
they're filling the whole stadium with
these oh this guy's got a dog
i feel like it's more distracting
doesn't it
they're raising money they sell it it's
kind of a nice way to for
the people to be engaged
with it it's kind of it's not a bad idea
not a bad idea
i can't help it like it looks so weird
i just i just had a friend of a friend
his aunt passed away who was a big
dodger fan
and they put a cardboard cut out of her
to like honor her
so i thought that was like a nice thing
to do you can get a cardboard cutout for
300 bucks wow actually
the price varies by location uh the
dugout
pavilion is 300 that's the premium ship
field level or loge
is only 150. excuse me a field level or
what
loge
no that's pronounced oh geez right yeah
dan what the [ __ ]
really load yeah it's lit load yeah oh
it stands correct
i thought it was lodge and yeah
you tried to come at me you better you
come for the gig you better aim
high i'm sorry there's a precedent of
you yeah
well maybe the president just got broke
maybe now the president is on your hands
okay it's the loge i'm sorry yeah the
load the load
i don't know are we gonna do the
pronunciation game
if someone makes it i'll play it okay i
can't make it because then your game's
ruined
you know it'd be funny if we had
call-ins and people could compete
and then they can win a prize we should
do that
the loge is 150 the oh you can get your
dog
for 150. so we were thinking maybe you
guys have ideas we wanted we're thinking
of funny
cardboards to submit like o.j simpson or
affiliate goes through an approval
system so they won't
probably approve yeah i was looking at
the
terms and conditions last night and they
they have a line about um
infringement on people's uh copyright or
image so i think you know okay celebrity
let me ask you a question if oj wanted
to buy himself a cutout would he be able
to
that's a good question they're like nah
oj he's a private citizen
yeah but but maybe they're like ah we
don't want you o.j
but if you guys have i mean the world is
yours this is yours truly
uh if you guys have ideas i think we
could slip some stuff
past the sensors though didn't you have
a good idea what was yours
i wanted to do ben affleck from the back
oh yeah that's hilarious
i feel like they did filter that one
though unfortunately we could try
that's so funny maybe it's a ben affleck
wearing a shirt of his back
you know but if you guys have good ideas
email to us at podcasts at https.com i
want to start buying cutouts
and seeing if we could get on screen
here's the uh whoops here's the
guidelines you tell me what you think
they show you the do's and the don'ts
right here
um oh so you can get like pretty much
the whole
upper body from waist up
that's pretty epic yeah
definitely a lot of maybe ian's high
school picture
just could buy like 100 of them
we don't need to subject the baseball
fans
i think that's cute that you can get
your pup in yeah that is really
here's a clip there was a dodger game a
few nights ago
and you can see the uh cutouts and hear
the cheering
uh can you can you give me some sound
turns on it lifts it down the line to
the right back towards you so these i
guess they haven't
sold these but you can see the cut outs
so those are all fake sounds and i gotta
say it sounds pretty good
and so weird to a level of comfort
where the lights turn on another team
they are doing
i can't decide if it's better than
silence
i think silence would be so awkward so
behind home plate they have a bunch of
cutouts
where are they they're
apparently not selling a lot of these
because that's an empty ass stadium
where's the cutouts well i i don't know
i'm not sure it's a timeline this might
have been before
no no they're there oh you're right i
just saw it yeah yeah
there's plenty of inventory available
well i looked
you see right there yeah these are all
cut out that's all they've sold they've
only sold like 100.
well i looked and um the the two
sections directly behind home plate and
then
all of the sections behind the two the
dugouts those are all
sold out already unfortunately yeah so
we gotta
try to get some good real estate
i think without audio would be just
super awkward but you know what i don't
know
everyone's trying their best in these in
these weird times
yeah i was watching the game last night
it was super awkward
oh because the cheers were super low you
could barely hear them
and the national anthem was kind of
weird did they do
fake booing like right now they only
have
cheering would be so cruel
yeah it's just bizarre it's an
interesting
thing though like so it's only cheering
because the players will get pissed
because you know it's just some dude
pushing a button and having the whole
stadium boo your ass
now the nba is actually really
interesting what they have gone all
out to protect nba players and the and
the uh
the season so basketball is attempting
to restart july
30th and they've created an entire covid
free zone
at walt disney world called the bubble
the entire nba team
and all of its associates is locked
in this bubble this quarantine zone for
three months
press will live in a separate hotel
they're not allowed near the player's
bubble anyone
entering the bubble is required to
quarantine for up to 48
hours until they register two negative
covid tests
any player who leaves the bubble will
undergo quarantine of up to 10 days
upon their return and they will need to
register two negative tests
there is more than a thousand people in
the bubble currently
players coaches executives medical staff
media partners and they're using tens of
thousands of tests if not hundreds of
thousands of tests over the course the
next three months
wow to get this done the restrictions of
the quarantine situation are a major
issue for many
players they're being isolated from
their families
but they have like barbers manicurists
they've got lounges dj
sets movie screens all this kinds of
[ __ ] inside
the bubble um they're all wearing these
titanium
rings inside the bubble look at this
[ __ ] that if you stand
within six feet of somebody for more
than five seconds
it vibrates oh they don't want you to
stay near each other no
huh they're so hardcore inside this
bubble
that's um so everybody on the side of
the bubble has to wear this ring
i like how seriously it's making it yeah
and they say
it measures temperature pulse
respiratory rate
and other physiological data that could
theoretically be helpful for detecting
if somebody has covid19
before they even exhibit symptoms
that's crazy players will also have the
option to wear a proximity alarm that
will notify player if he spends more
than five seconds within six feet of
another person wearing the ring
i wonder what uh jake paul would think
about all this
he's like i don't care he's like it's
chill still
he's like my house is is a bubble of uh
coveted apathy
we don't ask we don't tell
rings remind me of uh is this the sci-fi
movie where everybody's got the
crystal in their hand that vibrates when
they're when their time's up
the logan's run it reminds me of what
was that video we made
well i am no no no we made about the
the ring the o-ring oh yeah was it the
o-ring
um speaking of the a-ring
i honestly don't remember it speaking of
the nba
so a lot of players want to get involved
with the black lives matter and all
these social issues
so the nba released an approved
list of slogans they can use
on their jersey or that they can say so
here's a list of approved these are the
only ones they're allowed to say okay
black lives matter that's what's going
on say their names
you can't say their names you can only
say say their names
that's funny vote you can say vote
i can't breathe justice peace equality
freedom
enough power to the people justice now
say her name
uh there's a little spanish
yes we can little spanish lesson for you
guys
liberation see us hear us respect us
love us listen listen to us stand up
ally anti-racist
i am a man i don't get
what's what is i am a man
so i think it's a anti-slavery thing
really are we yeah because i saw i am a
man
and uh something that i was watching
they were they had footage of um
when when black people were
um you know fighting for their freedom
they had signs that i saw there oh
one like i saw a few people yeah holding
a sign that said i
am a man interesting i guess it uh i
just googled it i guess its
origins are uh you know it's very common
for white people to talk down to black
people and call them boy
and so it was sort of like i'm not a boy
i'm a man okay good
i am a man speak up
how many more group economics what the
hell is that
what that was that's just that doesn't
really roll off the tongue
group up into economics
education reform and
what is the social justice message here
mentor
you gotta read between the lines i love
that they crunch the numbers and they're
like
okay these are the ones okay yeah
so [ __ ] 12 didn't make it huh to make
the cut
[ __ ] 12. what's 12. it's
one of those it's an anti-cop chant that
people oh no no no no no i'm surprised
white devil wasn't on those troops
uh i'm also surprised like you know
we need to sound bite you now wasn't on
there
white devil death to america death to
america should be on there for sure
osama was right you know
jihad now
wake up sheeple the jews are in control
holocaust never happened
oh zach how could you say that's not
funny we don't joke about that
the truth zach it happened the numbers
are just greatly exaggerated
oh okay parody parody
oh this was horrible some players inside
the bubble were posting pictures of
their meals and i just felt awful
i mean these are professional players
these guys need to eat and these guys
are all rich dudes i mean like food is
probably one of their
their prides and joys so here is
one of their meals i mean that looks
[ __ ]
horrible one scoop of mashed potatoes
these guys burn like
these guys need like a lot of food
this is like school lunch [ __ ] one scoop
this is prison food
i was kind of imagining like it gets
worse
utopia inside the bubble this is just
ruined my image of the bubble
well here what does this do oh oh wait
this isn't one of those
here's another yeah
look at this one was even worse uh troy
daniels shares his first meal inside the
bubble
look at this it's like every like
airplane food yeah
that's like there's no calories there
these guys are these guys need to eat
like 5 000 calories a day
these are professional athletes how are
you going to serve them this
like professional note with it with the
logo
this is embarrassing this is how it came
right this is what was inside yeah
that's the worst i mean that is a
travesty
you better get some better food in that
bubble quick yeah
so one player actually here i'll read
you the statement
he ordered food because it was such a
nightmare he ordered ubereats
and they when they found out they made
them quarantined for 10 days
how are they supposed to eat he says
after the initial quarantine period i
briefly and accidentally crossed the nba
campus line to pick up a food delivery
i'm currently in quarantine and have
eight days left i apologize for my
action look forward to rejoining my team
for a playoff push bro you better give
them better food if you don't want them
going out to uber eats man
that sounds difficult
um this is what it's going to look like
when they come back i have to say they
did a nice job
they just covered the there you go yeah
that looks really good
the nba i think they're really they got
it together
well yeah they'll probably fix that
they better [ __ ] i mean i feel like
that's
the easiest fix if they already got
everything else like this sort of
there's like plexiglas they're they're
really crushing it i mean
they are not risking anything i have to
give props like honestly it may look
like
onerous like over the top but you have
to imagine that
if one of these players gets it the
level of contact they have it's gonna
it's gonna swim through the league
someone might die i mean
how awful if even one of these players
died how what i mean what a tragedy
would be but also for the benefit of
everyone if they want to keep this
sport going it would shut down if
everybody started getting it
they would have to shut down so this is
actually allowing for all of them to
continue yeah it's pretty
it is pretty epic i gotta give it up to
the nba uh pretty cool
meanwhile the major league soccer league
does not give a single [ __ ]
they're just doing it they just said no
audience and everyone else is just
all good
they're not i guess they have no
precautions going on except there's no
audience the crowd
i think they've got a kind of a pseudo
bubble going on as well
oh they do yeah
it's down in florida which that's the
same place the nba is doing it right
oh because here in the document somebody
said they just said [ __ ] it
that's the official note i have
i i think in regards to the um uh having
fake
audience cheering oh for the fake
cutouts and this one has no fake
cheering
which if you watch it again actually it
doesn't seem like a big deal
in this case actually the interesting
thing is that you can hear the players
yeah which is which is and they could be
pretty cool actually to hear the players
yeah you can actually
yeah um it's like when people edit music
videos
or or non-music videos um tv shows when
they edit out
the canned laughs yeah just they edit in
like smacking this is our life now
yeah you guys
probably saw this huge twitter hack
that happened last week so bizarre i've
never seen anything like this in my life
so many people got hacked and they were
tweeting out a bitcoin address
elon musk for example this is kind of
the gist of all of them
happy wednesday i'm giving back bitcoins
to all my followers i am doubling all
payments sent to the bitcoin address
below you send one bitcoin i send two
back
only going on for 30 minutes you know
i don't know who needs to hear this but
any time somebody asks you to send them
money so you can get more money back
you're being scammed just use your
[ __ ] brain people
why would you need to send him money
right why
why people oh that was another thing i
didn't talk about with our giveaway
so many people were getting scammed
and i i couldn't say it enough i mean i
would tweet every once in a while like
hey
you know don't send money like why would
i
ask you for money yeah so they were
getting this message like i need you to
send me five dollars
so that i can yeah why why would i need
you to do that
you know but it's not their fault
they're desperate they want the money
they want to believe they want and
i mean these people are just sick
[ __ ] freaks to take advantage of that
but anyway these guys hacked twitter and
hijacked
elon musk bill gates
what are these ones
what are we looking at these are a bunch
of uh bitcoin um
oh yeah they all they all got hit too
their message was a little different but
uh apple jeff bezos
it was wild we were watching in real
time yeah i just like kept crushing my
feed and
was seeing more and more joe biden
mike bloomberg bloomberg
wiz khalifa barack obama i think i said
that mr beast got hit
floyd mayweather uh
warren buffett you know
and then of course tenacious x who
passed away
uh who said smoking a fat okay i don't
know you got me on the loge one but it
is definitely not tenacious
temptation i mean i feel like it's a
weird name
i feel like i'm reading it correctly
temptation
temptation that's better that's closer
that's closer okay tentacion i mean
okay so how does he say his name xxx
tentace
tentacion right yeah
so anyway he passed away he was murdered
or something recently
smoking a fat blonde on my private
island giving out bitcoin to all my
supporters
i mean these guys are [ __ ] crazy to
do that
kim kardashian
and finally idubbbz which is unrelated
well that was so part of the uh
twitter's response to all of this is
they they locked all
check marked accounts but you could
still
retweet and so idubbbz in 2017 had said
if you're unverified you are superior so
he retweeted himself
to get that message back out there
because in that in that moment
if you were verified you couldn't use
twitter yeah it was frustrating i felt
like that kid
from the meme with his his veins bulging
in his forehead
like i couldn't do it
yeah so that was that was crazy yeah and
the
the bitcoin account through all of that
i think they they actually
i mean they've made what like 120 000
uh something like that yeah because with
bitcoin all the transactions are public
so you can see
but i think they were probably expecting
to make more than that
you know like a major felony and hacking
scheme
i feel like somebody's almost certainly
going to go to jail for this over 120
000
i think they were expecting more money
so there's no leads right now um
from what i heard they suspect that
somebody within the company
helped facilitate this
they'll definitely gonna find out who it
was yeah
but as far as i understand it there's no
uh definitive
lead twitter said we are aware of a
security incident impacting accounts on
twitter
and they're taking steps to fix it jack
dorsey the ceo said we had a tough day
at twitter
we all feel terrible this happened we're
diagnosing and we'll share everything we
can when we have more complete
understanding
of what exactly happened our team is
working hard to make this right
they believe 36 of the 130 targeted
accounts
the attackers were able to access dms
dms i wonder what like
bill gates dms looks like you think he
gets nudes in his dms
bill gates i don't get that vibe from
him
absolutely baby
yeah i bet you elon's got some wild dms
so that's that i thought it was pretty
interesting that jeff
bezos jeff bezos you got some weird [ __ ]
it's just i find it interesting like
that twitter has become
such an official channel of
communication it really makes you raise
your eyebrow like terrifying
i was waiting for donald trump to get to
to spam out bitcoin
and when you think about like donald
trump uses twitter as an official form
of communication
and when a hacker is able to hijack an
official
channel of communication of a leader of
a world leader
um it makes you scratch your head and
wonder if maybe we haven't created a
monster
oh it's definitely a monster twitter is
all social media but twitter especially
is like
i feel like it's taken over everyone
but it's you know it's
it's it's kind of messed up that we are
putting so much
into this what what is an insecure
mode of communication essentially is
what it proved
and and i was i had some concern you
know what if donald trump goes
and tweets out like hey the nukes are on
the way
at iran you know what i mean
um would it start a nuclear war probably
not but
it's still weird to think that that that
could happen
yeah yes shredder can we help you can
you guys see you can see shredder he's
climbing yeah he's poking through
better what's up you want to come say hi
come here sweetie
bye sweetie i'm such a good boy
you want to walk on the table first
hi dr disrespect has made a statement
and done a bunch of interviews we've
been following this story he was
mysteriously banned off twitch
nobody knows what happened um
he posted a comeback video
let's watch that oh yeah what do you get
here probably theodore i don't know what
dropped
something good on him i wonder if this
music is copyrighted but
it's basically just him standing in a in
a
in a alley and some kind of dramatic
uh you know 80s music
i probably shouldn't play the music but
so there's really not much to see
it's a song by him yeah but you still
never know
nah yeah i was just pointing that out
yeah that is
interesting so there you go
um he did a bunch of interviews
like the wall street journal and this
and that he's coming back did he already
stream on youtube or is that just
something he's planning
do you guys know uh last
last i heard he doesn't string no so
he's moving to youtube but
apparently it's not in partnership with
youtube
he's just streaming on youtube like
anybody can do
there was one interesting excerpt
from his interview they asked him this
specific question i'll read it to you
they say
one facet of this story is that and i'm
sure you're aware of this
there are people coming forward and
saying they know the reason you're
banned for example
slasher was on stream just yesterday
saying he knows why you were banned but
he doesn't want to save because he fears
it could make him
target of a defamation lawsuit what do
you make of that
he said listen again i'm not interested
in engaging in any of this stuff
or crazy speculation i'll say it again i
have a great community of loyal fans and
i'm totally focused on just getting back
to the champions club
and delivering great entertaining
content they said
okay buddy have you made any attempt to
understand what he's talking about
like if someone had dirt on me even if i
knew it was total [ __ ] i would at
least want to know what they thought
they knew
have you tried to contact him or any of
the affiliated parties he just said no
i mean he keeps letting he keeps letting
on like he doesn't know why
and i just don't believe that yeah me
too because
if you really don't know you would be
you would be
really loud about that that's outrageous
you know like yeah that's crazy
so that's it i guess we don't really
know anything more i mean he did this
whole
i mean it's kind of interesting he did
this whole kind of a puff piece with
washington post
without really saying or addressing
anything
about the ban
um
strange whole situation is just so
bizarre
we're gonna find out eventually right
wouldn't that be the biggest
like that would be the biggest
disappointment
of all time if nobody ever found out why
can you imagine
it has to be it has to be
yeah i don't know so there you go doctor
disrespect
still shrouded in mystery up next we've
got
gamer girl possibly the weirdest video
game
ever developed let's watch the trailer
hey everybody
abba cake 69.
oh my god so you're a monitor so this is
basically
it it's a simp simulator
where you're a moderator for this uh
twitter
or twitch streamer and you're white
knighting her
as she gets stalked by creepy fans
oh come on
moderate what do i do like moderators
what do i do
become part of her life ah like everyone
fantasizes
from moderator to become part of life
you know you're playing
role-playing as the real creep i'd be
more worried about you
why is it specifically a female gamer i
just don't get that part
gamer girl yeah maybe yeah i know what
do you guys think
you got that guys dude this is the most
pathetic i've ever heard again
what's it to you boyfriend's angry she's
streaming
what should i do choose the story
wow i'm sure some of them are being like
god i love her what do you think about
this game vin diesel
look how beautiful she is she is
beautiful would you send for vin diesel
right vin diesel would be a good
moderator
oh no what is she doing someone is there
she got into some weird [ __ ] how do you
end up here
oh dude her moderators failed her man
crazy right crazy simp simulator
how could anyone think that's a good
idea i don't know
we i mean all of us immediately thought
this must be a joke right when we first
saw it
yeah i think everyone did but it's
actually going to be really good i think
we ought to
play it i'm done yeah i'm not going to
play it
and um you know what i was thinking is
if the moderator
who's the simp you're playing has ends
up actually being the one to kill her in
the end
oh what a twist i mean it kind of did
seem like that right i don't know
but why is it specifically a girl what
do you mean because that that's what it
all
is you're you're a female all these you
know
who sims for guy streamers
no there's a lot there is a whole
environment about female
twitch streamers for sure yeah and i
mean things like this have happened
right i mean
there there's been female streamers that
fan
you know some fan gets obsessive and oh
yeah there's not where they live and
shows up at their house and stuff it's
there's a kind of a basis in reality
here there's a one streamer
uh sweet anita right
right i know of her because she has
tourette's like me
and it's kind of uh anyway that's how i
know of her but
she's a popular streamer and she's got
this stalker she's been
he's been like threatening and [ __ ] and
the police don't do anything and it's
just somebody's tweets and video in the
doc
oh you did anyway
developers it allows you to play as a
chat moderator for a female streamer
you make decisions about the post in her
chat respond to dms from her
and work to help her make
and help her succeed so she can fire you
if you mess up
apparently it's also up to you to
protect her from a predator in the chat
room who will attempt to hurt her in
real life that is so
weird i can't say it's not an original
idea
i mean it's it's different at least it's
just weird to me that it's
like come here be the guy that is to
save her
yeah white knight simulator yeah since
its release the trailer has been pulled
from youtube after facing widespread
backlash they made a statement they said
game of girls about the impact user
comments and actions have on a
streamer's mental health and well-being
the reason why
uh we created the game was to raise the
issue of toxic
environments which can often appear
online behind the anonymity of a user
without giving away too much gamergirl
is an empowering story
of a female streamer who with the help
of her moderator friends
battle the trolls and overcome the toxic
characters in her stream and also
i've been donating tens of thousands of
dollars to my favorite streamer
and she doesn't pay attention to me i
really desperately want to be her
moderator
or i will trick her into one of my sheds
and murder her
your choice assigned the developers
which is your own adventure
yeah uh yeah so here sweet anita who i
was discussing
uh describes her encounter from
with a stalker the stalker was caught
and detained last night he had a knife
on him
after taking my screenshots recording a
witness statement of the assault for me
and a friend and having his confession
to arrest me he's been released with a
caution
so this guy keeps harassing her she's
been showing like dms of him
threatening her i mean it's horrible i i
feel so bad for her
here's a video of her discussing she's
in the uk so
apparently yeah so here she is i am
at a stalker they have been stalking me
for quite a few months
actually um they've been coming to my
house
they've been sleeping pretty much in my
backyard watching the house oh my god
sleeping in the backyard the other day
sir some shopkeepers had to intervene
and kind of hold him back while he
chased after me
um because he waited outside my house
followed me into a shop
music waiting for me outside the shop
and
when i told him to leave me alone and
asked if he had a knife he didn't
respond
and when i said are you gonna let me
walk home alone he said yes and then
when i went across the road he started
chasing and two guys right out of the
shop
and grabbed him and then grabbed hold of
the gate
to um another area of of town and i so i
went through the gate and they held it
closed so that he couldn't pass them and
continue to follow me
it's not the worst thing he's done he
has actually physically assaulted me
what yeah yeah so the police apparently
can't do anything i don't know i feel
right
it's really horrible so obviously this
kind of thing does happen
but putting it in a video game format
i'm not quite sure
what that's supposed to do um but anyway
i do feel bad for her i i don't know
what
what quite i can do but
um i do look forward to playing gamer
girl oh gamer girl
i wonder if you get to i wonder if you
get to like
[ __ ] her game or girl no not like rape
but i mean like
you you successfully white knighter and
then she's like i love you
moderator because that's the fantasy
right
vin diesel would you what would you
think would you be her moderator
she's so [ __ ] beautiful yeah
totally that's why you want a mod for
her how am i supposed to sit over here
when i'm
looking at such beauty well you are you
need to focus on your task i know she is
beautiful but you do have a job to do
god i love her yeah i know that's why
we're all here but
you need to focus on moderating the chat
otherwise the stalkers are going to get
through
talk to me baby something tells me vin
diesel
taking very seriously yeah that's what i
was going to say too vin diesel are you
taking this seriously
he's out of control we need to fire him
we need to fire him
and finally our final story is johnny
depp
you know last last week we had a
headline of the year
i believe it was something about um
uh amy schumer's husband is not
circumcised
right according to jake according to
jake gyllenhaal
now here we have another headline and
you tell me if this tops aguila
johnny depp and amber heard accuse each
other of peeing and pooping
all over their house
i think it does it does johnny depp and
amber hurt are going through a really
messy
divorce as many of you probably have
heard is making big headlines
one of the stories is that amber hurd
apparently used to take
big steamy dumps in their bed
according to him and she just says no he
does
well they have the fact that they're
both accusing each other
one of them listen to that i believe
johnny depp in this case because they
have text messages to prove it here they
go the court
heard arguments over whether depp was
angry or amused when fifa sees were
found in the couple's bed after a fight
by the way as if it matters they're like
listen he was amused by the dump so
technically it doesn't according to the
daily mail he wrote in a text message to
a friend
quote my wife left a whopper poo on my
bed
and he dubbed her as amber as her
as amber turd instead of amber hurd
amber turd papa liked that one did papa
just laugh at that
yeah like that one that one let's see
johnny depp's libel trial against her
has taken a turn for the scatological
depp is suing over a 2008 headline that
called him a wife beater
and wasn't the court her arguments over
hers testimony that
depp attempted to spell her name in
urine
after a violent fight and depp alleged
that her took a whopper poo
in the couple's bed somebody tells me
this was not a healthy uh relationship
it really sounded like did you say that
uh
that he's saying that she tried to spell
something with her pee
no he spelled something and pee and then
she took a dump in the bed got it
uh eli if you took a dump in the bed i
would not appreciate that
no matter how bad our fight was yeah i
can't imagine
coming to that like what what has to
happen for
the both of them to come to that point
i don't know man i've never been that
angry in my life
heard has alleged that during the fight
depp slapped and shoved her leaving cuts
and bruises
estate manager ben king testified he saw
cuts on herd's arms
after their fight
king also testified he oversaw the
cleanup of the home
a process that took more than 12 hours
he said he was quite sure that there was
no
urine in the home daily mail reports i
did not see any signs of urine and i did
not smell it
as i would have had someone urinate
around the house
if i would have smelled it if someone
urinated around the house
that meanwhile has denied that he would
have been able to do such a thing with
his finger
severed so apparently depp claims his
finger was severed
when heard through a vodka bottle at him
heard said he did not he did it to
himself during an attack that made her
fear for her life man these people are
[ __ ] wacky
yeah if you're so if your relationship
is so toxic you're sitting in the bed
maybe it's
fine to just break up probably
i think they're working on that
it's like you know what when i come in
the bed and i find a [ __ ] in there i'm
like you know what maybe this isn't
working
right by the way our dogs did poop in
the bat
no no but not inside and also you could
tell the difference between a dog [ __ ]
and a human [ __ ] i'm sorry
yeah there's a big difference
alrighty well um
we have a surprise here today at the end
of our episode
an interview with one of the most i
would say
uh influential the the quick wettest
quickest wittiest
uh insult comedians to ever grace our
planet
we have with us jimmy lee the jersey
outlaw
for an exclusive interview he's just
been featured in hollywood magazine
and we're here to celebrate uh none
other than jimmy lee
so with that being said let's throw it
on over to jimmy
with us today is the
jersey outlaw and who who we're today
celebrating
being on the cover of hollywood monthly
which is um what is hollywood monthly
magazine jimmy you have not heard of
this magazine
although to be fair i don't read a lot
of magazines so what is this it's a
magazine for entertainment you know for
the arts and entertainment and we got
lucky enough through
uh a connection out in california to get
the cover and
a very nice article in the june edition
uh thanks to prather uh jackson
who's the uh publisher of the magazine
did you have to pay for this feature
jimmy
no oh that's nice that they give you a
really good spread
it's like when you open up it's all
about you yeah it's like all jimmy
elaine well i mean that's
love and respect yeah that's through the
agent's relationship not mine but in in
in
business it's relationships with people
so my agent who knows the guy asked for
a favor
there you go i got i got kind of got
lucky i've never seen that it's like the
jamie law
jimmy jimmy lee magazine there is other
stories
actually the following lady is uh ganja
the witch i don't know if you read her
spread the gondja
you see around halloween she's the one
with the mask on but it's not from covid
right yeah right of course let me read
an excerpt here
about um because they they wrote a
really nicely says jimmy lee
comedy is all too easy for jimmy lee
it's like
inhaling and exhaling air it's how he
communicates
that is to say jimmy lee is a wise guy
you're never going to get a straight
answer from jimmy lee
you're going to get a funny answer
sprinkled with brutal honesty
if he's telling you the truth you can't
get mad at him kavish
well i wish that was true maybe i would
have got on tv by now
i did notice that i did well according
to this magazine you have a tv show it
says
comedy realities tv star jimmy lee the
jersey outline is hit
comedy tv show dangerously funny is one
of the best rated comedy tv shows so i
wasn't sure well that's according to me
oh okay okay good you didn't understand
ethan and i have two fans they happen to
be in the attic right next to the air
conditioning units
you see right yeah of course yeah so
just so wait what are they referring to
the tv show though
the tv show according to me okay
but what is it your life or your like
your youtube channel
dangers there you go yeah polite light
and polite
so jim so what's your youtube channel so
the people know it's the jersey outlaw
jimmy lee
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw so
jimmy tell me um well congratulations
what's wrong with me no i would never
ask you that
hillary was thinking that what happened
did the doctor cut the cord your mother
hung herself
what happened jesus no i would never say
that the doctor slapped me and the nurse
slapped me a couple of times
something must have went bad i'll tell
you one way i did eat i looked up my
family tree
four dogs were using it things aren't
easy ethan it's rough
yeah no for sure i get that
i'll tell you nothing's going well my
kids are nuts they go to private school
they won't tell me where it is
you think it's easy jimmy i happen to
know your your son is holding the phone
yes he is my son is holding up
how do you know well i happen to be
trivia to the uh
the pre-interview portion where your son
was helping you uh
get the internet going i got two kids
ethan two good looking kids i got two
ugly kids i don't talk about the ugly
ones
hillary's not interested in hearing
about them and your son holding the
phone is he the ugly one or the
beautiful one
he's the good looking one otherwise you
don't hold the phone right yeah that's
an
honor you know the place of honor and
the jimmy lee family
correct yes your honor know your honor
that's why i'm in court a lot
i got to say that lawyer you know my
lawyer the guy works for that law firm
do we treat him in house you know him
no i don't do he he works for that law
firm do we treat him in hell
do them cheat him and how right yeah
that's good
that's all yeah the biggest law firm in
the
world as i understand it correct
so jimmy how about the jokes are going
to get worse the jokes will get worse
jimmy how is the uh career going at this
point
in time i know you're ma you're you are
um
primarily a dentist and you kind of do
the comedy
you know whenever you can you also are a
musician so how
how is it balancing those two worlds
being a dentist and being
uh dangerously funny at the same time
it's
it's difficult and you know we just came
back from the uh coven and the business
is
is tough some staff didn't come back
they're starting to come back the
revenues aren't quite where they need to
be
but uh i'm hanging in i'm working a lot
of hours and you know
i'm still doing through pandemic i wrote
a lot of jokes i think you saw some of
the uh
the videos on uh you know some of the uh
covert jokes and the trump jokes i was
doing a lot of writing and comedy doing
that and you know of course the
comedy tv show has a lot of subscribers
and followers and uh good hits on some
of the videos on the dangerously funny
street comedy stuff that seems to be my
uh my vehicle that most people know me
from
is street comedy street yeah
do you ever do you tell jokes to your
patients when they're on the dentist
table actually it's funny because today
there was a patient miguel
and i had him dying for about 10 minutes
i started with the famous quotes
and he was spanish i threw a couple
spanish one-liners in
you know i said i had a spanish
girlfriend but every time i made love
she took my wallet i had to break up
with her
wow once you go wreaking a job you'll be
seeking
and he was dying and that when he came
up for air i just kept going
and he said to me he said to me you're a
funny guy he said wait a minute
he says that yeah he's like you know
that's why you too
it was kind of funny um but it just
happened today
wow let me ask you this maybe
if i i wonder if some people who are
going to the dentist maybe don't expect
a routine i wonder if maybe some people
i i do i wonder if maybe you've lost
patience from
from that or maybe you think that you've
gaining retaining
um i would say may have lost a few that
don't get me
and uh and possibly the ones that know
me love me and they come
right so maybe a mix and match but i say
overall
i don't think it hurt me too much i
think it hurt me a little bit more
hiring dentists that saw the channel and
got offended
i lost a couple of stocks for interviews
because of that
not so much patience wait how do they
find it it's weird
i think they google my name and then it
cross
links to my stage name and they find a
video
and i i insult someone i got the faculty
i saw you in the casino buffet
stop doing that they get offended
because they don't know me as a person
well i do understand that that they
would yeah
right and i mean i've seen you go up to
big girl or big girls to use your words
you say you're
you're a big girl you say that to them
i can see why exactly they might find
that offensive but
you know yeah but hey what can you do
forget about it huh
you gotta forget about that's what uh
you you heard about nikki pompanis you
know nikki papanisilla
no nikki pompanisi had a rape charge you
didn't hear about nikki pump and niece
he had a rape george i'm sorry okay
we're doing a rape joke jimmy
no he had a rape charge downgraded to
tailgating he had a good lawyer
nikki pompanis
yeah how old was the niece 12.
holy smokes jimmy you know why no one
gets worse
ethan i got a i got a i got a buddy of
mine a doctor friend of mine he got
two years in jail for having sex with
one of his patients
having sex with one of his patients he's
a veterinarian hillary's a veterinarian
no
no no yeah that's right
you know what's funny about that story
but
it almost had a happier it had a happier
ending because like
you know [ __ ] an animal is better
than like [ __ ] a patient in a way
you know what dr phil said if you watch
dr phil ethan
yes of course he said if you're not sick
and you gotta have sex with an animal do
with a horse
this way you'll have a ride home you got
to think smart about things
right that's true that's a good point
no that's not a joke that's just good
advice that's very very sad advice
you know what dr ruth said hillary you
don't want to talk to your partner
during sex don't pick up the phone
say that one again i'm sorry you don't
want to talk to your partner during sex
don't pick up the phone
oh right right right right i can't write
these out jimmy let me ask you you seem
like a ladies
man uh through i throughout your career
when i see you you seem like a man who
appreciates beautiful women
am i wrong about that no that is correct
and that's kind of been one of my
my uh sizzles of the actors the bandito
girls which i
i did that when i did music and it
carried over with comedy and
and we mix it with some security guards
and
notice whenever you do your act you
bring some beautiful women along
jimmy are you what did you have you had
an illustrious uh
sex life i have to ask i know you're you
are a well
you seem like a suave dude i will be
honest when i was young i was really
good looking like not now but when i was
young right
and yeah i had i had pretty much a good
good run
but i'm married and happily married and
i'm fine now because i had that when i
was a kid
so i used the girls as props can you can
you tell me how many women you've slept
with throughout in your when you were
really in your prime
in my prime yeah put it like this i grew
up down the shore in the summer
and two or three a week to rotate wasn't
wasn't a bad move
and i wasn't the only one doing it i had
buddies just as good looking as me
and you know you don't kiss and tell but
back in the days i didn't the kid didn't
do bad now you know you people look at
me they look the other way
you know what i mean that's kind of what
happens when you get old so you said you
used the girls
as prop do you do you find that i use
them as eye candy as i can
when i shoot yeah it's the biz it's
showbiz
and i use security guards too in
and in regular cities i'll use the
security guards
i don't think it's necessary and i i
don't think
i don't know i wonder i wonder if that's
a good thing to do
you were wondering if you should drop
the girls yeah should i drop them
you may be right i get comments from guy
oh i like the bandito girls and
with security guards people actually
think i'm famous
you know they go who's he which is
a little bit as as an entertainer
because you and me both know i'm a big
nobody
but i gotta you know sometimes you dummy
it up a little bit and you pretend
you bring your sinatra a little bit once
in a while people go for it
are these girls able to keep their hands
off you if i was your wife i might be a
little bit worried
they can't wait till the shoot's over oh
really
and they get their money and they run
out the door and they say do me a favor
next time you do a shoot don't call
no they first of all they're told ahead
of time what's going to happen
and some girls if they're not confident
the coordinator will say you don't want
to do this it's offensive comedy
and he's going to be he's got a big
heart but it's going to be that kind of
comedy and if the girls are funny like
that they don't do it
but they're told so they know they're
prefacing you know before we start
right and we've had problems in the past
so now we tell the girls out of time
with the security guards i work with
two sets of guards so they know who i am
and there's no problem with them
um so
we're we were getting to the heart of
jimmy lee when did you decide to settle
down you were such a
playboy you were i settled down um
in my mid late 30s i i pretty much i've
been married a long time same woman
yeah same woman as far as i know unless
if there's a weirdo fooling around with
that
you know and i got a blindfold on and i
wake up with spring marks on my ass and
i played batman in the bat cave but as
far as i know it's the same girl
okay that's good good for you jimmy you
said i know the chinese people look
alike but you know let's let's not go
there because every time i think about i
want to order you know what i mean ella
last night i wanted 69 she said
it was her birthday last week and gave
her 61.
and you know what she said to me i'd
like to have eight dollars more
can you believe that can you do me a
favor jimmy
ask your son how does he feel about the
chinese jokes aimed at his mother
how do you feel about the chinese jokes
colt ethan wanted me to ask you
they're good they're good they're good
attiboy he said okay spoken like a real
uh lee right yeah he's a true
you asked you asked the question and i
lost my train of thought i went into a
joke
you asked me something uh
when did you settle down well no yeah i
settled down a little bit late because i
i i was a peter pan type of guy as a kid
and always fun so my actual dental
career took off probably when i hit
about 38.40
when i made it a business model and
decided to
do serious you know dental consolidation
by offices
but before that i had one location and
you know made a decent living but
we went out a lot and had fun i think i
grew up late you know what i mean i
know yeah i know i know i know exactly
what you mean
so how is the dentistry business
dentists make a lot of money don't they
well they do and i'm blessed to have a
business model so i can do very well and
you know sometimes be able to do my
passion while the officers run because
i have about 45 employees nine dentists
and managers and
great great employees that that work for
me and they're loyal and they're good
so i'm blessed but i also he'll since
the pandemic i've been working
12 14 hour days six five six days a week
to catch up so my job is not a
light-hearted job where
it's easy and i don't think a lot of
people could do my job
what is your job are you doing dentistry
are you just managing the business
uh two days clinical ethan and a lot of
admin and a lot of paperwork at night
everything related to running a business
and it's very hard
it's getting harder jimmy what are we
pulling in are we pulling in like seven
figures is that what we're looking at
seven figures um um i'm i'm high right
right in that area but the company does
about six million yeah
wow well yeah but
he said nobody ever gave me anything in
life oh absolutely
like a dog i was a waiter as a kid and
when i do
comedy i work like a dog and no one gave
me nothing i never
had any kind of entitlement syndrome and
felt
if i didn't work i was going to get paid
and i made sure you know when i work for
people
i worked hard and was a good guy and and
i expect the same for my people and i
work
alongside them i don't ask them to do
something i wouldn't do
and you know i work just as hard as them
so i lead by example
jimmy what what's the how are you guys
dealing now with the covet what's the
procedure
to see people well what we do is we have
them wait outside and then when they
want to come in we have them wait
outside and then we
move the uh the dental chair outside and
we work on them
and we spin on them so there's a chance
to catch the covey
and when they catch it we say we don't
have nothing to do with this though you
spit on your patients jimmy
oh yeah and by the way i found out the
disease is young and asian so now i'm
interested in dating
so there's a lot about this disease
jimmy what's the craziest thing you've
seen as a dentist because i'm sure a lot
of wild [ __ ] pulls in
i'll tell you what happened to me the
other we got a lady come and take her
clothes off
and she said doc i want to have these
two pulled this cavity filled
two weeks ago and did you and did you
oblige
no but i had a lady grabbed me in the
privates and
i was getting ready to number she says
we're not going to hurt each other are
we i said no we're not
that was a very awkward situation too
but really you must have some wild
mouths pull up into the dentist office i
mean in your long illustrious career
what have you seen inside someone's
mouth that really stands out to you
um well i had a lady coming last week
hillary you'll appreciate this
and uh last week we cleaned
we cleaned our teeth and uh when we were
done i said you can go over to the sink
spit and then you can get dressed and go
and she did
that's disgusting you asked for a little
joke a little side swipe there a little
love and
uh no wait a minute wait a minute i had
a guy come in a month ago he had a brown
neck and i said how do i get my teeth
white i said
go home and get a brown necktie you know
what i mean i must not joke up too by
the way uh what
i guess i don't understand that one the
brown necktie can you explain now a guy
came in
with a brown necktie i forget how to
joke quit i forget it but i'll tell you
heath and what i did do i figured out a
way to hide my bad breath guess what i
do
hmm what's that hold up hold up my arms
hold up your arms mm-hmm i'm afraid
that's how i hide
that's how i hide my bad breath hold up
your arms
how does that hide your bad breath body
odor body owner under your arms i'm not
i can't write them out here
i can't write them out right see let me
tell you something about
jimmy are you saying you put your
armpits in your patient's face
correct i have to do it excellent
i wish you were my dentist jimmy i would
be getting spit on
raped and uh wait a minute guess what i
give some of my patience hillary
what jimmy why do you think he's calling
out ela
what am i chop liver you don't want to
give me any jokes no ethan ethan guess
guess what i give you my patience i give
them gears and guess what else i give
them
what's that i give them electric too and
then they i turn them on you know what i
mean
gas and electric forget it
forget it i thought you're going to say
you [ __ ] on them because you say i give
them gas
no that was the guy in the in the one f
that guy passed away about six months
ago the guy in the third
one f'd up dennis that that shot on the
floor
he passed is that sad that's true really
nice guy
st steve whalen from new york it's hard
to get
right jimmy do you do you find it i find
it interesting that in between jokes you
kind of just dropped
that somebody close to your past also he
wasn't
he wasn't close to me let's get that
straight right now
are you glad he's dead no
no because you just were like hey i
don't know i don't know that guy is not
close to me
no i met him one time and that was the
end of it
is your son want to be a comedian jimmy
is he inspired by
do you want to be a comedian absolutely
not he shook his head no no
what does he want to do is you want to
be a dentist a proctologist it's a job
that you start at the bottom and stay
there
we'll have the top and bottom covered is
that true uh does he want a proctologist
that's uh
what do you want to do dentistry he
doesn't know but he's leaning towards
dentistry
oh good for him he's got a good career
lined up for him yeah well this way you
could pull
out at the right time you know
absolutely he wouldn't be here if you
did
exactly well that was when i was
supposed to be a girl
he just made a face can he hear us
or can he only hear you no but hillary
you know my problem hillary clinton
may i speak frankly okay
i appeal to people ethan and hila they
can do me absolutely no good that's been
my problem my whole life
mm-hmm
appeals to people that can i appeal to
people that could do me absolutely no
good
i guess i just being honest with you
okay someone at home got that
no nobody got that not even not even
your people out there in tv land it's a
tough crowd
dan did you get that no
um well jimmy i want to say
no need to apologize going through here
i feel like you should write a book with
your jokes and then
at the end there's like the explanations
like in case you didn't understand
do you even get the joke a footnote yeah
jimmy you have really beautiful skins
flipping through this magazine i have to
say that you have a really beautiful
skin
regimen like well that is called
facetune
of photoshop and and and
makeup they always say ethan and gila a
little powdered little paint makes you
what you wait
remember that i need to get whatever
you're on
yeah i got a famous quote gila you ready
yeah abraham lincoln he said all men are
created equal but you know what
he never went to a nude beach
abraham lincoln definitely didn't say
all men are created even
he said all men are created equal but he
never went to a nude beach because it's
false
that that's implying that men who have
have different sized penises
jimmy
jimmy are you packing heat what kind of
what what are we looking at downstairs
four inches and that's the win wow so
you got
you got some yeah you've got like a beer
but i graduated high school mag to come
loudly
all right yeah absolutely for sure yeah
yeah i told my wife you know you want to
puff on a magic dragon tell pinocchio a
lie
she understands right sure of course
excellent i feel like i remember ethan
when the air was clean and the girls
were dirty back when i was a kid
jimmy just like you i think you should
try to develop a drinking game
where it's just cards with your jokes
okay should we do a game with milton
bradley and sell it
jimmy wait what i don't know who's that
jimmy
um how do you feel that our president
is doing uh right now yeah well
i think right now he's got better
connections with russia than with
melania
that i'll tell you that's interesting
that's a good observation how do you
feel he's
um handling covid i think he's doing a
wonderful job i mean you ask him he'll
tell you
he's not shy about it right right i'll
tell you i'll tell you that what i
figured out about him
he puts a bag of doritos on his face he
puts it at medium temperature for about
eight minutes and look how nice he looks
he's doing a really nice job with his
makeup in fact he's on matching tinder
right now are you excited about sports
coming back
oh i can't wait i'm such a sports fan
i'm a big football fan
my wife's my favorite tight end wow he's
got a line forever yeah
jimmy are you flying on planes right now
during covid oh
yeah not only do i fly on planes when
the pilot makes a left-hand turn now he
puts his hand
out the window i'm on weird type of
planes in fact now the no smoking sign
smokes when you go in
i i gotta tell you those are weird
planes are a little strange
yeah i am on the wing looking in
sometimes
jimmy um
are you going i know you're not supposed
to be are you sheltering him oh my god
are you going off oh no that's not what
i asked
are you sorry do you all go out in
public are you doing things are you
staying at home mostly just being safe
no i go out in public i'll eat at
restaurants outside
and i'm i'm working you know we're ppp
compliant in the offices
and at night i'm you know i'm with the
blow up doll you know about my new girl
right here the blow up though takes my
breath away
you know about her yes
and does your wife know you have a
blow-up doll well she does because i let
the air out of her night she flies
around a room so you know she plays hard
to get
my wife hears it yeah so it's a little
awkward yeah it is a little it sounds a
little awkward
and your son is your son making a weird
face right now
yeah my son's that doesn't care for me
very much
you know well he cares enough to hold
the phone yeah he's holding the song
he's been holding the phone very steady
for a long time he is holding the phone
steady
it's the least he could do for you now i
want to tell you guys
this is being serious for a minute i
want to say thanks because you guys
believe in me and
you help me out on the promotion end and
it means a lot to me a
comedian going absolutely nowhere with
jokes people don't get any more
from 1982 that's trying hard to get a
little somewhere in the business
you know when you get a little love from
some people that have a little bit of a
following
it means a lot from a little guy so i
just wanted to thank you oh well
thank you that's from my heart well
thank you very much i was waiting for a
punchline somewhere
no no i'm not a cardiologist but i just
want to say that because you had me on a
podcast you came out to meet me at
frescoes a few years back
and uh i just for people that believe in
you when you're a little guy
starting out struggling it means a lot
to me so i just wanted to say that well
of course jimmy
thank you um there was one other
question i wanted to ask you um
is your son going back to school with
the kovid what's your thoughts on that
how old is your son i guess i i don't
know blake's doing it blake's gonna be
home and uh colby's going back what half
time called
i think he goes back two days and he's
home but i think with what's going on
with it getting worse
it's almost you don't want anybody to do
anything right now until it flat the
curve flattens down a little bit
yeah you got to be a little i mean jimmy
i don't know your age exactly but
i would be i mean are you concerned
about getting coveted um i know you're
well double nickels so not quite yet
not quite yet but you know getting there
getting there
what does double nickels mean well
what's a nickel
five what's double nickels healing knows
55. double nickels that's your ten cents
well jimmy who you voting for
in november probably truman
i don't believe he's on the ticket are
you sure
i think i'll have to double check maybe
barry goldwater because these two guys
stink
barry okay i'll write him in put barry
gold
you know who i may vote for zack
i mean look at that patriotic vote for
that yeah we're voting for zach
for zach with that saxophone he played
to me i'm i'm putting zach in
zach is that uh when did you play was it
saxophone or guitar exactly
i did yes thank you i appreciate that
you want to hear the weird things that
stevie wonder didn't even see you
when you did it you're right
jimmy um yes you're close
floating off your face do you notice the
glasses don't really sit on your face
they kind of float
do you know what i mean like like they
don't rest on your nose they kind of
just jiggle around i didn't notice
i just had my nose done oh okay i just
found that was
interesting is that a do you
specifically not put them down all the
way for a reason
no this is the gynecologist glasses the
guy that puts his hands in
to the lady says your hands are in the
sink doctor she says oh i have the wrong
glasses
uh-huh wait what's the joke he wore
these glasses as a gynecologist
and he was with the patient says doctor
your hands are in the sink he says oh
i'm sorry about him
oh because he thought the sink was her
vag bingo
big mistake that's a big
misunderstanding
zach was nursing he was the assistant
that day
yes right yes i was zach forgot
don't you feel like you could make a
great drinking game from
how's the girl how does the drinking
game go i don't know i'm not
dylan let's get me famous with it with
the game man that's that's cool
whatever think about it for you this is
what's going on
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw at hollywood
monthly so
do what do you want you want people to
buy the magazine do you want people to
go to your youtube channel
what do we want the people to do to
support jimmy it's not a youtuber
youtube channel uh viewers subscribers
um views on videos uh tick tock what are
we gonna take
there we go we are on tick-tock
the jersey outlaws oh that's where we
need to be oh
get that get that nice crowd of yours on
tick tock
and youtube and uh may i say something
to you uh
ethan that probably nobody has ever said
to you may i
absolutely not no may i want to see
yes please please i actually like you
well that is nice i have never heard
that
thank you very much thank you jimmy
thank you very much
as always on fire on point
there he is all over the place
tick tock youtube everywhere else
hollywood magazine jersey outlaw the
jersey outlaw the jersey outlaw people
the jersey outlaws in the house he's had
sex with
many women hundreds would you say many
women but no men
no man sure i wasn't i didn't asian men
are out of the question
asian women are all right jimmy the fact
that you brought up men makes me think
you've had sex with men
what about non-asian men
no i can't i can't i went on a vacation
many years ago
a gay case i found out a vacation i
found out everybody comes
right i didn't want to do that i'm sorry
ethan i had
i had some problems yeah well that
sounds good if everybody's coming well
all the gay guys when they go to the
supermarket you find them in the fruit
section it was a little weird so i
didn't want to go to that round that
sounds offensive possibly but i get it
yeah jimmy are we talking hundreds are
we talking thousands what are we talking
here
thousands i know some may have had that
many women yeah
a lot over 100 but no more no more oh
way over a hundred yeah
yeah you see did you see what i did you
see how we reacted over 200
are we pushing 500 more
whoa we need a [ __ ]
ethan pull up my facebook page and look
at the picture when i was 25 real quick
let's pull it out facebook let's see the
young
beautiful boss the black and white
picture of me let's see the box 25
and you'll see why over 500 yeah
i mean yeah but no more spider doesn't
work well that much i'm older now
do you still now when you um this i'm
apologies
i'm destroying uh for being crashed but
at a certain age i know that
like do you still have a libido does
anything come out oh yeah yeah no
i do but when you get older you change
you know my priorities are different i
work a lot of hours and you know
i love to do comedy and on weekends i
relax i like to go to the diner and eat
with friends
sexes it sounds like
you get a little bit older but when
you're young you know anybody talks and
breathes and moves and you know
spider wakes up and your spider wakes up
in the summers down the shore think
about how many people are down there for
three months
think about that i grew up down in mar
gate down in by atlantic city
and the casinos and when you go out at
night and you're good-looking and young
things happen wow like it was your
full-time job
no no no because in the winter then what
happens is
in the wintertime it's different because
the unit's not busy down the shore so
you got to get get it out
when it's busy it wasn't busy in the
winter in the summer you ever catch
anything find a photo
zack's looking you ever catch anything
jimmy during those days
well you know everybody used to clap
when i did my show i said don't do that
i had that couple
yeah yeah yeah i hear that knock wood
i use the uh what do they call it the
raincoat what do you call that zach the
raincoat
i believe it's called a condom yes
yes so i was pretty uh
what's the word heal is self-conscious
safe yes no idea yeah the ringtone
called the raincoat are you and your
wife still active
very active we're in separate bedrooms
we barely talk to each other
once in a while well we do have sex uh
ethan almost every day in a week you
know almost monday
almost tuesday
zach is looking feverishly i can't have
like 15 different facebook pages
jimmy lee the jersey yeah there's like
jimmy
jimmy why do you have so many facebook
pages there's so many different pages is
it under your real name
no go jimmy lee public figure
jimmy it has a picture with me in the
models jimmy
why do you have so many facebook pages
i have old ones that i don't use i only
use the one i don't know why
but why are they jimmy um you know what
would be interesting to try for a video
instead of those models
it would be interesting to see your wife
just kind of like how
he how she reacts to your madness
she's oh she she makes faces and walks
away
that sounds like an interesting video i
agree
i can't get the wife and the kids to go
on that's what would make it great
bring your son and your wife to react
instead of the models yes
would you want to do it colt colby made
a face he may but we can't tell mom
right cole
yeah cub's making a face he can hear us
i
can you hear what they're saying called
oh colby can hear you i don't think i
can hear you okay he can't hear you
yeah colby what do you think about your
dad's
um pursuit of comedy do you think he
should give it up
and or do you think he are you proud of
your dad
what do you think cole should i give it
up or stick with it be honest
yeah be honest with us give it up
he said give it up hmm how do you uh
why do you think he should give it up he
clearly cares a lot about it
why should he not good because he says
i'm not i'm not really relevant and good
does that hurt your feelings jimmy a
little bit
oh oh did you think your son thought you
were a good act
uh well colby's the one more like me so
i guess i did at one point
he just says i'm too passe like hope is
that what you said
i'm not caring well you do do like the
offensive kind of comedy which is
probably something of the past that yeah
especially in 2020
it's the old tiny insult comedy yeah and
it doesn't go
like but you know what is weird my agent
roger he says you know no one does it
it's funny that there's not a niche for
you because
no one does what you do yet people won't
bring
in because it's so politically correct
and there's a metoo movement with women
so it's almost like if you touch someone
or you insult someone
you're going to like end up in jail and
get beat up where when rickles would do
a roast and he'd say to the black guy to
take the show he's done clean the tables
up
you do that today they want to grab you
beat you up so it's kind of like the
stuff that i do which is what i remember
to be fair jimmy you could own slaves at
one point and we don't
allow that anymore obviously that's an
extreme example but
times do change right right right so
my problem i think was my age is i'm not
as adaptable to change
and the style i have i do and my
videographer and
agent said if you changed and there was
a production lady in la sue haber who
said if you change like develop you you
probably could hit
your your clothes you're wearing are
outdated your jokes are outdated
but you know change that's what you told
me
really i like your i like your your bit
uh your routine
i mean i can't how do you tell a singer
that sings country you start singing
motown
i'm who i am as an artist you can't tell
tony bennett to sing like
uh the one connection band exactly
zac is in the matrix trying everything
to find this photo
i i uploaded three of them to discord
and go in my face
okay so we've got some we've got some
all right let's see
find the black and white photo of me
wait this isn't young
or well well you tell me if this is what
you meant jimmy
here is this oh can jimmy see what i'm
saying
no you'd have to screen share okay i'm
gonna screen share jimmy and you can
tell me if this is
it's a black and white picture why don't
you send it to me
oh it's black and white this isn't an
attack it's a modeling shot i did when i
was like can you send it to zach
24 zach and you're not seeing anything
hold on can you go on my facebook you
can't can you call can't leave here
can i hold that you gotta
jimmy hold on one sec dan go ahead yeah
there's uh i'm on his facebook there
you have literally thousands of pictures
like i've been scrolling for the last
five minutes it's not an exaggeration
there it's thousands go into albums go
ahead and find the black and white house
you'll find it
so your family doesn't seem
i don't know how to i i would
i'm a little sad that we it seems like
you're you're
i don't i don't want to cause a rift or
anything but
it's got to be difficult to pursue
something that maybe everyone
i don't have the support of my family
with this my wife not really my oldest
son doesn't
care colby kind of helps me with it with
stuff and videos and he kind of gets me
but
he said if you change you could probably
be more successful
he was giving me good advice what two
months ago cole he was telling me the
truth
i guess it's hard to change because of
my hobby what is it kobe what is it
about
his act that you think he should give it
up i mean
just just give us a little more insight
because it seems like
why should i change it or give it up
called what's wrong with you yeah yeah
it's too old
too old style
the comedy bit is too antiquated it's
too antiquated the offensive
type yeah i kind of have to agree
and that's what sue that's what the girl
lady said in california
she said you're still nice looking for a
middle-aged guy if you start wearing
john varvatos
and you do uh observational comedy you
are funny
but you have to change your style and
your look she said it's not hard to do
what's your son's name kobe i found it
colby colby
colby who's your favorite uh comedian
who do you like for comedy called i
don't like comedians he likes basketball
he doesn't like comedians
damn he likes sports he's rejected the
art of comedy jimmy
yeah he's rejected me it seems like
i gotta i gotta pick and uh okay we got
the picture oh
this will show you why we got the
picture jimmy
this is the guy that [ __ ] your sister
and mom in the same day
look at the outlaw chiseled beautiful
look at that hair
that was the kid in the day that was in
like 1990.
well i wasn't a lemon drop i wasn't like
my loafers
zach would be a second choice yeah zach
of course everybody wants to [ __ ] that
thank you thank you zach would be my
second choice
dan would be my first choice oh really
well jimmy we've learned a lot we've
learned a lot
uh we've got a lot of insight i wonder
if we can develop a new comedy
maybe style maybe you can just give it a
shot
maybe work with your son that's what
this girl susan told me to do
yeah because you're you're you're a
funny guy
no pun intended don't piss everybody in
the video
modern comedy well why don't you just
write some material about
you know what's something you're
passionate about i mean dentistry for
example what's a topic you know
we can make some observational humor a
story
i think slow it down a little bit you
know right
i do think the fact that you're a
dentist is very interesting
so a combination of a comedian who is
also a dentist
but modern style comedy look maybe may
work
i love the dentist comedy connection you
know they say
they say that dentists are the highest
rate of suicide of any profession what's
the deal with that
oh yeah he just dropped that
the big one ethel well they kill
themselves why are
why are dentists killing themselves well
i think they're depressed
why why are dentists depressed have you
looked at what dentists mostly look like
they're ugly so you look at the mirror
at yourself every day and you're ugly
you you kill yourself i was blessed with
uh
a receding hair line a five head not a
forehead
gay glasses a shirt from 1987. jokes
from 1977
and uh and a little bit of money and
and i'm carrying on zach's tradition
where he plays guitar
i do gay jokes in las vegas and we're
both going absolutely nowhere
quick if i may say so even though zach's
uncle was a gangster with the mob and
i ran the bootlegging [ __ ] and whatever
all that
and sir duke was a good friend of his
and stevie wonder and they played guitar
together
zach jimmy i gotta i mean i i'm not i
haven't been following you for like a
fair couple of minutes
so yeah i figured i was i haven't been
following myself
jimmy i do want to see you succeed i do
want to see you do well thank you
i love that i'd love to have you back on
the show and maybe
maybe try to develop kind of maybe a
more modern
yeah more modern kind of stick
maybe about race relations or something
about about what
about race relations black lives matter
something like that
maybe we could talk about the ball game
did your son just whisper something
how do you play did your son just
whisper end it
what did you just say he just said ended
he whispered
oh come on yeah your son knows how to
read the room
guys thank you a million times over
we'll have you back on let's see
yeah we love it we love the outlaw
okay all right jimmy thank you for your
time
thank you let's stay in touch okay thank
you colby for holding the uh
the phone there for us thank you very
much he's got a steady hand too i have
to
i have to tell him he's doing very well
you guys thanks for believing in the
little guy i love you guys i mean
all right i appreciate you mary take
care have a wonderful day you too bye
bye
bye well
as a hell of an episode i had a lot of
fun this week with monster episode
a monster episode doing two episodes
this week
next week guess what another two
episodes we're back the week after that
five no i don't know but i'm like go
away two
yeah my goal i really do want to do five
episodes a week people
that's one every weekday that's right
well we'll start with two for now and
we're really um
i guess i maybe don't want to give
everything away but we're we're building
up towards
some some real epic uh upgrades to the
h3 podcast
in the uh medium term here so i guess we
can share
that we are going to move to relocate
yeah we're relocating well you know with
kovid we're not even really
capable of being in the office so we're
taking this time to find a new space
and to build out like a more proper
studio yeah because that studio was
getting
it was always kind of small and um
especially now with the virus it's like
doesn't really allow for much
in there no yeah so i'm excited i think
um
you know the future is bright for the hd
podcast
so even if you know everybody on the
internet hates it
i'm still in baby so those few of you
who do like this show
fear not because we're not going
anywhere right yolo
right we're in it until nobody's
watching
until the only people watching is dan
because i'm paying him too that's right
they've been fired
all right guys have a great weekend we
love you we appreciate you we'll see you
next week with two
juicy fat whoppers of shits in the
episodes amber turds
all right guys we'll see you next time
you